hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well yeah there's
there's a couple different ways in which
it plays out one of them is the fact
that no matter where you're coming you
already have some sort of moral theory
you don't realize it yet necessarily but
some of you when we study these things
this semester some of you could identify
yourself as a motorists and that's okay
if you get to the end of the semester
you're still in emotivist
yeah maybe some problems right but maybe
you haven't been offered anything better
some of you can probably when we get to
the day ontology section you can
probably look in the mirror as you're
reading Kant or Ross some of you will
identify with
military you'll say yeah it's makes a
lot of sense and that would be because
you've been thinking like a utilitarian
this whole time you just didn't realize
it was called that some of you will be
finding more affinities of virtue ethics
some of you may also as we go on to you
know next week stuff and we start
looking at this might makes right
you know philosophy of through Simha cos
you might say well that's really
attractive to again hopefully by the end
of the semester you've seen some
problems with that but but if that's
where you are right now that's okay now
a moral theory asks two questions that
are very general they're universal and
you don't necessarily ask these
questions explicitly yourself one of
these is how often have you got into a
conversation where you brought this up
well you know they're doing a lot of
looking on Wikipedia about moral
theories and thinking an awful lot about
this and I think that good for human
beings is an X Y Z and then your friend
next to you said why I've been doing the
same thing too I have a different
opinion however and I think they're good
for human beings is this
faded back does that intent how it goes
it does you know you're unusual right
that that's not even how it goes for for
philosophers most of the time most of
the time you're asking questions like
for me what is my good and this will
vary from time to time is your good the
same as it was when you were five years
old what was the best thing in the world
when you were five Pokemon so TV shows
and yeah I was I can't you find I guess
you know you guys like Pokemon go
camping birds are us the store it's all
for the whole experience okay so now is
that the center of your life now oh he
wouldn't be much of a college student if
it was it was Pokemon or candy unless
you're gonna become a candy ologist
obsessed with Star Wars
yeah well Star Wars is interesting
because there's the well we'll get to
that at all there's a narrative there
all right I suppose to a certain extent
there is a Pokemon I don't think you can
make any case that there's any sort of
narrative with candy unless you talk
about you know okay so now these
questions are interrelated McEntire
saying this this is what you're
typically asking what is a good person
you have to figure this out at different
times and you could be mistaken about it
right maybe you didn't fully understand
what the good was for you
kid and maybe you didn't understand it
when you were 16 and maybe you have a
much better handle on it now at 20 21
and maybe by the time that you're 28 you
might have a better understanding of it
it really depends on how you live your
life and what you do with it right but
in order to answer this question well
you actually have to sum up somewhere
down the line raise this question
because you're not something radically
new you know I mean you've heard this
before
you're not a unique snowflake you know
never existed before and your pattern
will never exist again I mean even
unique snowflakes are still snowflakes
right they are still more or less the
same they just have slightly different
characteristics I don't know if it's
even true that
I suspect probably not the case many
there are
so you've raised this question another
key question that follows from this is
once you've figured out what the good is
what you humans have to do to attain and
do you ask that
you know most of the time when you're
doing carrying out your for practical
deliberations about whether you should
go out or study whether you should use
the credit card or not to buy a purchase
that you probably can't pay off you know
the next balance time whether to go out
with this person or with this person
whether to believe this person or that
person when you're engaged in that sort
of thing are you asking generally about
well what you have an in beings you have
to do a team to do it how many of you
every time we've done that
few times maybe you ask something more
like this
somewhere along the lines of when you
typically ask yourself I wanna have a
good time what should I do
it's good having a good time is you know
a value for you and McIntyre doesn't
have any problem with you know people
having a good time then you actually
engage in practical reasoning of some
sort you know should I go to the movie
that we have a Student Center
should I get bars across the street you
have to go somewhere else there's no
bars over there wow that's surprising
for college you know probably good so I
go to the bar which I go to the movie
which I may be studying ethics should I
call up an old friend from from home all
these sorts of things those might be the
thing to do to attain your good and each
one of them raises different different
possibilities where you write so no one
is that these two questions are going to
relate it as well in asking this you are
sooner or later maybe has to raise this
question and so this is a good place to
bring up something that
there talks about yes sir what he asks a
question if you've waited through this
whole taxing he said wow there's a lot
of stuff here what is this actually
about okay so he asks a question at a
certain point yes a lot of questions but
one question that he says this is what
my article is about it says how much of
a moral theorist does the plain person
need to be so that's your how much moral
theory do you actually have to like
explicitly make part of your life this
is sort of like asking what do we
actually need to study for ethics class
what do we need to come out of ethics
class having learned maybe even master
and he gives you two answers one of the
answers is probably more satisfying to
you than the other one so let me start
with the one that's that's probably more
satisfying yeah
he says the plain person needs as much
of a theory as will enable her him to
identify with the significant
alternatives are which now confront him
or her and to understand why and how it
was in the past that he or she did not
did or did not make mistakes in the
acting in one way rather than another
perfectly clear now let me read it again
but let me read it again with brakes or
hey the plane person needs as much of a
theory as will enable her um so this is
you to identify what significant
alternatives are which now confront I'm
just gonna switch to them confront them
so let me just stop there when you have
a choice to make you have significant
alternatives right a moral theory should
I should help you to identify what those
alternatives they actually mean what
their significance is so to use the
Louie CK thing apologizing or not
apologizing in a way you know when the
girl is saying you just have to breathe
out and
word come out right is that all that's
going on with saying you're sorry if it
was then it'd be really easy to say
you're sorry all the time wouldn't it so
when you are you know I'm gonna do this
sort of spatially you're moving forward
into the future values as you know
habits are like a timeline and you got
two choices you've done something wrong
I can apologize or I can say screw you
not going to apologize what are the
moral impacts of those those things what
are the values at stake why would a
person say forget it I'm not apologizing
with you what might what might be
motivated instead yeah
pride sense of you know again who is CK
think she's a [ __ ] you did tell me that
I should apologize and that's sort of
like saying I'm higher than the rest of
you why do you apologize you could
apologize for a lot of different reasons
by the end she's ready to apologize why
she's a she wants to get up those
handcuffs to avoid punishment
are there any better reasons to
apologize
yeah she got kind of touchy there's a
recognition that some genuine wrong or
harm has been done to another person and
that's recognizing the value of another
person but they're not and this is
really the opposite of pride isn't it to
be proud as to say I'm Anna to recognize
the value of another person is to say
well you matter to it and maybe you
actually matter more than I do that's a
pretty important choice then isn't it
there's more to it than just breathing a
word sorry or breathing another word
like get away from me so the moral
theory if it's worth anything should
help you figure out what am I actually
looking at what are the values so that's
one part to identify the significant
alternatives and to understand why how
it was in the past that they did or did
not make mistakes in the acting in one
way another so a lot of things thrown in
here if you think about how your your
decisions go you're in the present
moment you're deciding about the future
usually the near future but perhaps the
long-term future because there could be
consequences you have a PSP and I gave
my children all of you at the past did
you learn from your past at all have you
made mistakes have you failed have you
recognized your failures all of them all
you know we'd be interesting for me to
ask you this eight years from now
the same question because if you were to
ask me that your age and then ask me
eight years afterwards
ask me another eight years afterwards
might be you know like wow yeah I've
learned so much more sense than and I've
learned so much more about how much I
screwed it up back then and why are you
that back I have quite often ethics is
not just about being given the mat for
this is the right way to go this is the
wrong way to go it's about sort of
retrospectively looking back and saying
this was definitely not the right way to
go and here's why this is what I've
learned moral failure is part of our
experience and the question is what we
do with it how do we orient it in terms
of these things and again do you
typically approach you know mistakes
that you've made in the past by you know
whipping out here Aristotle or contour
the mill and saying now what do they say
about that what is the good for us all
how am i how am i doing and in
comparison to that good what would I
have to do to get myself at this point
to that point you know you usually do it
in much more determinant things in
specific ways with your story